so modoc let's talk about modoc
um i just read through again uh head
games
the the series head games you wrote with
jordan bloom nice and uh i really enjoy
the little coda you guys
i guess you co-wrote at the end where
you compare modoc to batman
because i loved the sort of i loved the
way you played it i'd love for you to
explain
to people what that means because at
first you're like that doesn't make any
sense but i think really when you watch
the show it becomes like a very
very beautiful analogy well you know
he's struggling to
he's living this extraordinary superhero
comic book
big life but he uh in batman's case he
has to maintain what looks like a very
normal uh kind of uh normie existence
uh and that takes energy you know he
can't um and i think in the movies even
more they
went into you know i don't want to be
batman forever i want to eventually stop
having to do this and
live a normal life modoc is has that
same kind of ego and pathology of i am
going to have both not only
will i be able to rule the world as
emperor modoc but unlike these other
losers like dr
doom and you know people like that i can
also have a family that loves me and
kids respect me
i can have there is no such thing as
compromise or sacrifice in modoc's
life what's interesting about sort of
the journey i was just talking with
jordan about this is how this show was
announced in 2019
and it was announced in a completely
different scenario it was announced
in the studio and i'm wondering you
started was there any point where you
were like
were you like this hard work we all put
in it's all for nothing was there ever a
point where like modoc's not going to
see the light of day and that's a shame
because
it's it it's you can tell you know all
the work that went into it it's such a
such a
lovingly made show and i'm wondering if
there's any point you're like well that
was all for nothing
no i don't i think we were always going
to happen we we didn't really have
the problems the other shows had we were
always full steam ahead in terms of
working with stupid buddy and getting
set together and getting you know
creating characters and
you know building things so if the if
any of that was going on
that was behind the scenes and i was not
involved in that i was more focused on
the writing and the
structuring everything that was that was
my focus
and you mentioned the writing i you have
soul writing credit on
episode four which is a very a standout
episode
it's uh if this saturday be for the boys
i wrote that i wrote that episode but
there's so much that went in from the i
mean
all the episodes get worked over by the
staff so there was a lot of
contributions by
other members of the staff on that one i
you know it's just
that was the one that i broke and that
was the one that i was writing but trust
me it was a
like all of them they were a group
effort um
but yeah i really like the idea i love
in comic books the whole
kind of in between the issues idea of
what do they do in the downtown or what
happened
were there adventures that just came to
naught and then what does that feel like
when it's over with
if you are a negative like modoc how do
you
deal with that so i i really wanted to
kind of get into that area
you're writing you're producing you're
also the lead voice actor on the show
and i'm i'm wondering
how do you find a voice for modoc where
it's not
always this comic book parody where it's
sort of a mix you know you come down
occasionally and you sound
more human you go up occasionally it's
common how do you find that in the room
or is it is this just something that
comes to you naturally
it just kind of came to me as we were
luckily i had a lot of time in the room
to write and
see how they were writing his dialogue
and then you know you just kind of take
a lot of the warmth and
self-deprecation out of your voice
because this character doesn't have it
and then
the moments when he's vulnerable are
only private moments he doesn't show to
anyone else it's more to himself
or to someone who he feels like is
inferior to him he's like if you reveal
that i just did this i will kill you so
they're
kind of you know you just sort of play
it that way just someone with no
no no sense of humor about themselves i
really can't believe that a modoc show
exists
because i've been a fan of that for a
long time it's just i feel like now
because of how all consuming pop comic
book pop culture has become
it sort of led to this and i'm wondering
i when i think back on
on your filibuster episode of parks and
rec
in 2013 that kind of has become the like
forewarning or or go-to example of like
what was going to come in the years and
i'm wondering if you ever think back on
that or if anyone's ever pointed out to
you that's
that's just sort of like the the
prophecy of what
where we'd be in 2021 i mean that at the
time it was just me
going why aren't they yelling cut i'm
panicking i'm going to dump everything i
know out of my head
because you know i just i love that show
so much i didn't want to do a bad job
but
like maybe i was unconsciously tapped
into something that a lot of people were
tapped into but it was all
just kind of in the air and it just
landed on me for some reason
i don't know i wasn't looking to do a
prophecy i was looking for
a job yeah well i mean that's as good as
any reason to do it it's just it's just
been interesting to me i'm like wow that
was
kind of spot on and here we are there's
a modoc show and i i could not be
happier about it
uh to just sort of uh ask you about what
you're working on right now i think
are you working on ap bio right now we
just rap we wrapped on friday
uh i'm just i'm just curious what what
it's like behind the scenes
when you're on a show that's brought
back out of sh like
sheer fan reaction when it's
you get that sort of concrete people
like this show so much they want it to
be brought back even when it's it's been
it's very gratifying it's like we did
something that really landed with people
and
and really clearly meant something and
connected and sometimes it takes
a network time to see that because
they're looking at different numbers or
looking at different
you know viewing uh criteria or whatever
i don't blame the network they were
doing the best they could and
it was really cool for them to go yeah
let's bring this thing back
it's amazing and so before i let you go
i'm just i i'm wondering
what you want people when they watch
modoc
what they want to see in themselves when
they see this this character that is
like
debut in the comics as this like
grotesque computer monster what do you
want people to see in themselves when
they see modoc
i mean imagine if you're on your worst
days or when you were jealous or
or competitive or feeling inadequate and
needed to
that you had cosmic level weaponry at
your at
at your reach what would you do would
you you know
that that kind of that kind of feeling
amazing uh well again
thanks so much for taking the time to
talk to me and as
a as a modoc fan i i know i know there
are dozens of us out there i'm very
happy that this show exists
all right thanks man